the HP Officejet Pro 8 7 to 0 is a
high-speed high-performing printer for
small businesses to play big in office
environment
you know you really design for a lot of
people following the users interactions
we kind of find that if you know they
don't like the protruding trees on the
printer let's say you forget to extend
the tree the paper actually falls on the
floor so this is one key pain points
that we found out and therefore we
redesign that at the same time we also
challenge ourselves to reinvent the
printer what we actually did is that we
rotated the chassis of the printer and
by rotating that actually self contain
all the papers within the printer itself
also we look into like the accessibility
of our pronounce so what we did is that
will elevate the ADF the auto feeder as
well as the scan Bay so the user can
retrieve the paper easily and you also
can see the control panel right in the
front so it's a very user centric kind
of design then the juices stand in front
a kind of can access everything they can
see the pronounce we can change the end
do their tasks easily and efficiently
for office in HP we are very customer
centric so we do a lot insights and
trend studies and trued audits we kind
of find the pain points of the customer
what your needs are brilliant office and
I think at energy when you see a user
appreciate your design it kind of
motivate you to do better and that
really helped me to design for that
experience for a user
[Music]